The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: How about
I propose this?
We go through
knapsack because it's
on the Pset, not knapsack
but a variation of it.
If we have time, we do
a couple variations.
If not, maybe not.
And if we have time,
we do at a distance.
Let's see what happens
after knapsack.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How many
people got the difference
between polynomial
and pseudo polynomial?
OK, so we should
definitely do knapsack.
AUDIENCE: Constant
factors, they don't matter.
Oh wait. [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, they do.
PROFESSOR: So the thing is
it's not constant factors.
That s there is not a constant.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
knapsack problem.
So the way I look at it.
You're a thief.
You somehow made your
way into a vault.
That vault has n items.
AUDIENCE: Way
better than camping.
PROFESSOR: Each item has
a weight of si pounds,
and after you get
out of the vault,
assuming you make it
alive and everything,
you can sell it for vi
dollars on the market,
so this is how much money
you get out of it, vi.
Well, now the problem is the
only thing you have with you
as you enter that vault
is one knapsack that
can carry at most s pounds.
If you try to put
more stuff in it,
so if you try to load it
up with more than s pounds,
it's going to break as you
try to escape from the vault
and stuff is going
to fall on the floor,
and then many laser beams
will shred you to pieces,
so that's undesirable.
So we can only load the
knapsack with s pounds.
Now, given this
restriction, we want
to make as much
money as possible
out of the whole
thing, so we want
to load up the
knapsack optimally.
Does this make sense?
Everyone remembers?
Good.
So two ways to solve it,
graphs and dynamic programming.
We're going to do both.
Who wants to go
for graphs first?
Who wants-- OK, never mind.
Majority has been achieved.
How do we represent this?
First off, let's
represent the solution.
Our solution is which
items we chose, right?
So we can phrase
this as n decisions.
Each decision is a
true/false decision,
and it indicates if you take
that item with you or not.
So di says, do I take item i?
So now this looks
more like a game.
You are on a TV,
there's a game show,
and you get asked n questions.
Do you want to take this
item with you, yes or no?
If you somehow
manage to get items
that are more than s
pounds heavy, you get shot,
you don't make it to
the end of the game.
Otherwise, when
you leave the game,
you make some
money and the money
that you make depends on
what items you took with you.
So now this looks
like the game problems
that we used to solve with
graphs in that you have
decisions, those
decisions are moves,
and they get you through
a graph of states.
Now, let's see
what's in the state.
What do we need
to keep track of?
First, we need to keep track of
what item we're thinking about,
right?
And then there's something else
that we need to keep track of.
AUDIENCE: How much
capacity we have.
PROFESSOR: Yep, very good.
So the reason I
need that is when
I'm deciding whether I'm
taking an item or not,
I want to know if I'm
going to get shot or not.
If I take too much stuff,
I'm not going to make it,
so I need to know if this item
fits in my backpack or not.
That's equivalent to knowing
how much weight I have left.
So s pounds.
Let's say this is
capacity, how much weight
left in my backpack's capacity.
This is equivalent to how much
weight I have accumulated,
the total weight of my items.
Weight of the items
I have taken so far.
So the sum of the weights
of the taken items.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] left.
Isn't it the total minus?
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm
saying they're equivalent,
so if you know one, you
can compute the other.
They're not equal.
Knowing one lets you
know the other one,
but this is more useful in terms
of putting the graph together,
I claim.
We'll see if that
is true or not as we
try to put the graph together.
So what's a node?
What's an edge?
AUDIENCE: An edge is
putting in one more item,
and a node is a state.
PROFESSOR: So what the weight
going to be on an edge?
If the edge means
I'm taking an item,
then the weight is
going to be what?
AUDIENCE: The weight of
the item you're adding.
AUDIENCE: The earning
associated with that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I like this better
because in the end,
my goal is to maximize
earnings, right?
And I'm going to feed my graph
to a shortest path algorithm.
Maximize earnings,
minimize path weight.
They're the same
issue, flip sign.
So I'm going to say this is
the value of the item almost.
Does this work or not?
Negative value of the item.
I have to flip the sign to turn
it from a maximization problem
to a minimization problem.
So shortest path will
give me the shortest path.
That's going to correspond
to making the least
amount of money if I
don't add this minus sign.
So what's a node?
AUDIENCE: Is it a
unique set of items?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: A unique set of items.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the state in a
node is going to have
i, which is the item that I'm
looking at, because this way,
I'm going to have one
node for each item.
And what else did I say
I need to keep track of?
AUDIENCE: The weight
of the taken items.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Weight of taken.
So this is sort of
like the gas problem
where you have to keep track
of how much gas you have
as well as where
you are on the map.
Sorry if it brings bad memories.
Let's talk about an example so
that we can draw a graph for it
and see what things look like.
So say we have three
items, and say our backpack
has five pounds.
And my three items
are a golden statue,
value $10, weight, four pounds.
These are 1800 dollars
when money actually
used to be worth something.
Crystal ball, you
can sell this for $4,
and it weighs two pounds, and
someone in the previous section
wanted a fountain
pen, so we're going
to use a fountain
pen that's worth $7.
Culture is worth a
lot of money, right?
And weighs three pounds.
Really ancient fountain pen.
I don't know how
people wrote with it.
So how do we draw
the graph for this?
AUDIENCE: We'd make a tree
where each level the tree
is take item i, or
don't take item i.
Make a big binary tree.
Does that make sense?
PROFESSOR: So if each
level of the tree
says whether I'm
taking an item or not,
and then I have two
descendants, then that's
going to be 2 to
the number of items.
So that's going
to be exponential
in the number of
items, whereas we're
going to end up in a solution
where the running time is
proportional to the
number of items.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I mean, it
makes sense in some cases,
if you have fractional
costs or something.
By the way, all these
weights are integers.
Sorry I didn't mention that.
My bad.
But I like the idea of having
some sort of levels based
on items, so let's say I'm
going to have a starting node,
and then I'm going to have some
sort of layer for item one,
some sort of layer for item
two, and some sort of layer
for item three, some
sort of vertical layer.
How many nodes do
I have in a layer?
One node for each
possible weight
because I promised that in a
node, I keep track of the item
that I'm considering and
the weight of the items I've
taken so far.
How many possible
weights do I have here?
AUDIENCE: Three weights.
PROFESSOR: So my backpack
holds five pounds, so what
are the possible sums I can get?
How many?
AUDIENCE: 4, 2, 3, 5.
PROFESSOR: So far, I
heard 2 3, 4, 5, 6.
Who wants to bid more?
AUDIENCE: Not more than 6.
PROFESSOR: So the
answer is 6, right?
The possible weights are from
0, which is an empty knapsack,
until weight 5, which
is a full knapsack.
So weight 0, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, and I'm
going to start
drawing the nodes.
AUDIENCE: You could
have weight 10.
PROFESSOR: We're
never going to fill up
a knapsack with more than 5.
Otherwise, we're going to die.
AUDIENCE: Why do
we have 6, then?
PROFESSOR: Because
I can't thank.
Thank you.
So this node, the first node.
Weight in the backpack, 0.
We're looking at item one.
It's connected to
the starting node.
What outgoing edges do I have?
What do I do with item one?
I can take it or not take it.
AUDIENCE: You connect
the edges 4, 2, 3.
Am I answering a
different question?
AUDIENCE: If it's item one,
shouldn't it have a weight?
PROFESSOR: So those have two
numbers in them, i and j.
Sorry.
They're in the wrong order here.
1, 0.
So I'm looking at item one.
So far, I have zero
pounds in my backpack.
Looking at item two with zero
pounds, looking at item three
with zero pounds.
Looking at item one with
one pound in my backpack,
item two with one pound,
item three with one pound,
so on and so forth.
So if I'm looking
at item one, and I
have zero pounds in my backpack
so far, what happens if I don't
take item one?
Where do I end up?
AUDIENCE: 2, 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I'm looking at item two
after I'm done deciding,
what do I do with item one,
and if I don't take item one,
then I'm not going to have
anything in my backpack.
So this edge corresponds
to we don't just take one.
What if I want to take item one?
Where do I land?
AUDIENCE: 2, 4.
PROFESSOR: All right.
2, 3.
2, 4.
So if I did take
item one, then I
had zero pounds in
my backpack before.
Now I have four pounds, and
I'm still considering item two.
What about edge weights?
What's the weight
of the edge that
says I don't take item one?
What's the weight of the edge
that says I do take item one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Minus 10.
PROFESSOR: All right.
0 and minus 10.
That minus lets us
get the shortest path.
Now, suppose I'm in 2, 0.
What are the outgoing edges?
AUDIENCE: It's the same as
making a giant binary tree,
right?
PROFESSOR: It's not going
to be a tree because I
can have multiple paths
from a root to some node.
AUDIENCE: But this looks like
it's taking the same complexity
as building a tree if you were
to carefully build the tree so
that you don't have unfeasible
solutions on the tree.
PROFESSOR: Then you're actually
doing dynamic programming.
You're not building the
tree if you're doing that.
You're still converging to this.
You're probably thinking
this and you said binary
decision tree, or at least
that's what I understood.
You're probably thinking
of the right thing.
We can see if we're thinking
the same thing when we end up
looking at the running time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The goal here is to
have the most valuable items
possible in the bag
in terms of money?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the
negative 10 weight
that you have there was
because that item was $10.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
And in the end, we're going to
give the graph to the shortest
path algorithm.
So yes, speaking of the
goal, what's the answer here,
by the way?
AUDIENCE: 11.
PROFESSOR: 11.
How do I get 11?
AUDIENCE: By getting
the last two items.
PROFESSOR: So I take
the ball and the pen
and I get 11, right?
Everyone on the same page?
So I'm at item two.
I have zero pounds
in my backpack.
What are my outgoing edges?
AUDIENCE: To 3, 0 and to 3, 2.
Wait, sorry.
That's the third item.
PROFESSOR: No, second item.
You're good.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it be
3, 3 because the third item
has three pounds?
PROFESSOR: I said I'm
looking at the second item
and then I'm deciding
where I'm going.
So this graph has
a problem in that
when I get to the third
item, what do I do?
So I need one more layer here,
which means that I'm done.
AUDIENCE: I was saying that it's
the outgoing edge from 2, 0,
it's the weight
of the taken item,
so if you decide to
take the third item,
shouldn't the outgoing
edge go to 3, 3, not 3, 2?
PROFESSOR: But when
I'm at layer two,
I'm only looking at item two.
So I'm looking at the
items in sequence.
First I have to decide,
am I taking item one?
Then I decide, am I taking item
two, and then I'm deciding,
am I taking item three?
While I'm here, I
don't see item three.
I only see item two.
AUDIENCE: Aren't those weights
on the left side, though?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
These are backpack weights.
So down here, these are
pounds and these are items.
What are the weights
on the edges?
0 and negative 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How about this other node, 2, 4?
What are the edges
coming out of it.
AUDIENCE: 2, 0.
AUDIENCE: 3, 4.
PROFESSOR: So if I decide I'm
not going to take item two,
but I already have four
pounds in my backpack,
I'm still going to end up with
four pounds in my backpack,
and I don't get
anything out of it.
And?
AUDIENCE: That's it.
PROFESSOR: And that's
it, because if I
try to take the second item,
that would put me overweight,
so the edge would
go out of the graph.
Therefore, it doesn't exist.
AUDIENCE: You can remove it,
and then you go back to 3, 0,
right?
Is that not allowed?
PROFESSOR: No,
because when I'm here,
I don't know how I got here.
I don't know if I
had item one or not.
The benefits of doing
it this way is here,
I'm just looking at item two.
I do not know how I got there.
I do not care what
I'm going to do later.
I'm just looking at
one item and making
one decision based on that.
Does this make sense?
Where do I get my answer from?
AUDIENCE: Can you put a
final node on the right side?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
one way of doing
it is that I'm going to have
a final note on the right side
and connecting everything to it.
AUDIENCE: Do you need the
done nodes right there,
or could you have just skipped
done and connected 3 to that?
PROFESSOR: So I can
do that, but then it's
going to be hard to
reason about edges.
This makes it easier
to reason about edges
because when I'm
looking at this layer,
I'm still going to
have edges deciding
whether I take
item three or not.
So it would be confusing to
have all the edges pointing
to the same place.
I can, it's just that the graph
would look more confusing.
By the way, if I'm at 3, 2,
what are the outgoing edges
from 3, 2?
AUDIENCE: It's just
all horizontal.
You can't take anymore.
PROFESSOR: So I can be
done with two pounds,
and that means I
get 0 or I can take
item three, and then
where do I land?
AUDIENCE: Negative 7.
PROFESSOR: Does this
make sense now somewhat?
AUDIENCE: So what about this
dynamic programming style?
PROFESSOR: We'll
get there in a bit.
Before, let's see what's
the running time for this.
So one way of
finishing this up is
we connect everything
to one destination node.
Another way of doing it is that
we connect the source nodes
to everything here with
edges of cost 0 and say,
well, this is how much
weight we're going to waste.
So if my solution path
goes here and then goes
somewhere through
the graph, it means
that I'm going to waste
one pound of capacity,
so my backpack is going to
have four pounds when I'm done.
AUDIENCE: Would it be
[INAUDIBLE] or infinity?
PROFESSOR: What
should the weight be?
Good question.
AUDIENCE: This is
not possible, right?
To get from s to 1, 1.
PROFESSOR: So I'm saying
that if I get from s to 1, 1,
this means that I'm
wasting a pound.
My backpack will have
four pounds of stuff
and then one pound of
capacity will go to waste.
AUDIENCE: Isn't
there another way
to waste it on the right
side if you end at the top?
Or not at the bottom, basically.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you're
not double counting
in terms of losing stuff?
You're representing
losing weight
on the left side
and the right side.
PROFESSOR: Well, if I represent
losing weight on the left side,
then the advantage is that I
have a single destination node.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: That dot.
PROFESSOR: So this
is the source.
The destination is this guy.
I can waste capacity
here, so that
means I can say
that on this side,
I don't need to waste stuff.
On this side, I need
to arrive at done 5.
That's the advantage of doing
it this way, aside from the fact
that it's going to map
to dynamic programming.
There are many ways of doing it.
I can choose to connect
the source to 1, 0,
and then look at all the paths
here and choose the best one.
I can connect the
source to everything
here with paths of some
weight, which you guys still
need to tell me what it is, and
then I can look at the answer
here.
AUDIENCE: Cost 0.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
So this is another way.
And yet the third way
would be to only connect
the source to the
first node, and then
connect all these done nodes
to another node with cost 0,
and this is equivalent to this.
The reason we're
doing it this way
is because this maps
to dynamic programming.
AUDIENCE: Easier.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It maps closely to
how the DP runs.
AUDIENCE: I mean is it
possible to do the DP such
that you do it the
other way as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can flip the DP around, too.
How are we doing with this?
So then I hope the running time
analysis will go really fast.
How many vertices?
AUDIENCE: v or three.
PROFESSOR: OK, so v is?
AUDIENCE: ns.
PROFESSOR: n layers, right?
n plus 1 layers, actually.
AUDIENCE: n times weight mass.
PROFESSOR: n times
capacity, right?
So it's actually n plus
1 times capacity plus 1,
but I don't want
to deal with that,
so I'm going to use
order of so that I
don't have to deal with that.
How many edges going
out of a vertex?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So at most, two
edges per vertex.
So how many edges total?
AUDIENCE: ns.
PROFESSOR: What shortest path
algorithm am I going to use?
AUDIENCE: Bellman-Ford.
AUDIENCE: Topological sort BFS.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
choose the second one
because it runs faster.
So Bellman-Ford's running
time is V times E.
If I use the DAG algorithm, that
means topological sort and then
a DFS.
That's V plus E.
So please, whenever
you have a dynamic programming
graph, this is the answer.
It's never anything else.
It's never Dijkstra.
It's never Bellman-Ford.
It's always this.
And this means?
AUDIENCE: ns.
PROFESSOR: So this
is the running time
of the graph solution.
AUDIENCE: If you
use BFS, do you need
to put in the dummy nodes
for the edge weights?
PROFESSOR: If you use BFS.
Yes.
So then the running time
would be bigger than V plus E.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So then the running time
depends on [INAUDIBLE]
multiply by s again?
PROFESSOR: This isn't doing BFS.
This is doing the
shortest path algorithm
for direct acyclic graphs.
It's the DAG shortest path.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Were you here
before Thanksgiving?
AUDIENCE: No
PROFESSOR: Right before?
You missed the algorithm.
It's in the Dijkstra
lecture notes.
AUDIENCE: But
basically, you don't
have to put in all
the dummy nodes?
PROFESSOR: No.
So you do a topological
sort, and then
you only consider a
node once, and you
look at all the edges
coming through it
and make a decision
based on that.
So this is the running
time, this is the algorithm,
this is the solution.
What if we do dynamic
programming instead?
Instead of nodes, we
have sub-problems.
A sub-problem maps to a node.
The same things that we
decided about this data
that we store in a
node, the same things
are going to apply to the state
that we have in a sub-problem.
So what are the sub-problems?
First up, how many sub-problems
am I going to have?
AUDIENCE: n.
AUDIENCE: ns.
PROFESSOR: I just said
that one sub-problem
will map to a
vertex in the graph.
ns vertices, ns
sub-problems, right?
Come on, guys.
Bear with me.
Get more cookies.
Are the cookies still there?
Please pass them
around and eat them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One sub-problem would
be getting the most amount
of money for that little weight.
At one pound [INAUDIBLE],
how much [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I like that,
so let's start writing.
What is the maximum value that I
can get using a certain weight?
If I label the nodes
indices i, j, I'm
also going to label the
sub-problems using i, j.
So I'm going to say
that sub-problem i, j
is, what's the maximum
amount of money
I can get by using a
weight of at most j,
and you said
something about items,
so we have to figure
out which items.
Which items?
Anyone else can help her.
You already did the
hard work, so you
have most of the
stuff filled in.
Feel free to jump in.
AUDIENCE: Greater
than or equal to i.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Sounds good.
We're going to number the
items starting from 0 this time
because we're going to have
a dynamic programming table,
and that means we like
zero base indexing.
So the items are going
to be 0, 1, and 2.
0 is the statue, 1 is the
ball, and 2 is the pen.
This means we're going to
look at suffixes of items.
First, the empty set,
no item, then only
the pen, then the ball
and the pen, and then
the statue, the
ball, and the pen.
And we're also going to
consider how much weight we
have in our backpack.
So let me write this again.
0, 1, 2 here, and weights
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and this
is going to be our DP table.
Now, how are we going
to compute this?
DP of i, j is?
AUDIENCE: Maximum.
PROFESSOR: All right,
a maximum of something.
Good.
Perfect way to start.
How many decisions do we have?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
It's the same as in the
graph problem, right?
Once we solve that, this
should be pretty easy
because it's really
very similar.
So the two decisions
are, do I take item i,
do I not take item i?
If I don't take item i,
what situation do I land in?
So suppose I don't take item i.
AUDIENCE: i plus 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
i plus 1.
So I have to make up my
answer using items i plus 1
all the way through n minus
1, and how much weight
do they have to have?
AUDIENCE: j.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Now suppose I do take item i.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: i plus-- no, no, no.
PROFESSOR: You're thinking
of the right thing.
We're making some money, right?
AUDIENCE: Value i.
PROFESSOR: Value i.
So this is how much
money we're making.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Plus dp i
plus 1 j minus weight i.
PROFESSOR: Make sense?
OK Now I only have to do
one more thing to make sure
this code doesn't crash.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
What's the third term for?
PROFESSOR: This is I'm
making some money, right?
This means I'm going to
have to look at the items
starting from i plus
1 and i minus 1.
And now I took item
i, so that means
I have si pounds in my backpack.
So the remaining items must
weigh j minus si pounds
because I'm going to add
the si pounds for this item,
and in total, I'm going
to have at most j pounds.
Make some money,
lose some capacity.
AUDIENCE: Did we [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
This is what happens when
you move from the graph
to dynamic
programming, or you can
draw the graph the
other way around.
AUDIENCE: So could you
have also done plus si,
and then done
something else as well?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Plus si--
AUDIENCE: If you did
plus si and then you
did some other check
case that was different.
PROFESSOR: Well, I do
need to make a check.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So that's greater
than or equal to 0.
PROFESSOR: This thing, right?
Because otherwise, the
code is going to crash.
So j minus si is
greater or equal to 0.
I think this means j is greater
than or equal to si, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
At least for me, the natural
order when I have the graph
is to consider the moves
that by making in the game.
I'm answering the
questions one by one.
Do I take this item?
Do I not take this item?
When I'm in the DP,
when I make a decision,
I want to have the full
information on that decision.
Whether I take the
item or not depends
on what would happen with
the items following it.
Representing it
this way allows me
to make the decision right here.
AUDIENCE: If we'd done
prefixes rather than suffixes,
we could have done it the same.
PROFESSOR: It would have been
exactly the same as there.
So we taught dynamic
programming over many years,
and it turns out that
people understand suffixes
better than prefixes,
and the graph format
makes more sense
that way, so that's
why we're doing it this way.
It's for your own sake.
Trust me.
Or at least we think so.
AUDIENCE: Where
does suffix come in?
I know what it means.
PROFESSOR: These guys.
These are the sub-problems.
Nothing, item two, items
one, two, zero, one, two,
so it's a suffix of
the set of items.
AUDIENCE: How come you're going
backwards rather than forwards?
It doesn't actually matter if
you go backwards or forwards?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
In the end, we're going
to look at everything.
So we need two things.
We need to know where is
the answer going to be,
and we need to know what
are the initial conditions.
Actually, I lied.
We also need a topological sort.
So where do we want to start?
AUDIENCE: First one.
PROFESSOR: Where is the answer?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The lower
right hand corner.
I mean, if you have all
the [INAUDIBLE] nodes.
Oh, we don't have a
Done column, do we?
PROFESSOR: No.
Well, so the answer will have
considered all the items,
right?
AUDIENCE: Top left.
PROFESSOR: So which i?
Almost.
So the top left corner means
I looked at all the items
and I have an empty knapsack.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so the max
of all of the first column.
PROFESSOR: So the
max of all columns
would be the answer if the
weight here would be equal,
but I said the weight has
to be smaller or equal,
so the answer is easier.
I don't have to do a max.
AUDIENCE: Bottom left corner.
PROFESSOR: I can only look here.
So this means that I will
use a weight of at most s,
because this is s, and I
will have considered items 0
and larger, so all the items.
This is where the answer is.
And in general terms, that
means DP of what and what?
So what's the
bottom left corner?
AUDIENCE: 0, s.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain again
why it needs to be DP 0, s.
PROFESSOR: I think it's
easier to look at 0,
s and see how it maps
to the sub-problem,
and then convince yourself
that this is the answer,
so let's do that.
DP of 0, s means i is 0, j is s.
So this is going
to tell me what is
the maximum amount
of dollars I can
get by using a weight
of at most s-- agrees
with the initial problem--
and using items i or greater
than i, or 0 or more, so
items 0 through n minus 1.
These are all the items.
This is the maximum
capacity, so this maps
to the initial problem.
And that's why I did this.
That's why I don't have
an equal sign here.
AUDIENCE: And if you
did have an equal sign,
then you would be changing
your sub-problems?
PROFESSOR: The recursion
stays the same,
but I have to look at all
these to get the maximum.
Someone suggested that.
AUDIENCE: If you
put an equals there,
you're going to have to do
something to the DP such
that the equals
actually is captivated,
because you can't
just arbitrarily--
PROFESSOR: What do
you think of this?
AUDIENCE: Something there is
going to change, isn't it?
PROFESSOR: No.
I think this works.
This stays the same no
matter what the sign is.
The only thing that changes
is where is the answer
and what are the
initial conditions.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So there's something
else that changes.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Initial conditions.
Good.
I like that you're
thinking about that
because the next problem
changes pretty much that.
The sign changes and
then these change.
What's a good topological sort?
This should be pretty easy.
If I want to generate
a topological sort,
what variables do I iterate
over, and in what order?
AUDIENCE: i.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And you're pointing at n, right?
AUDIENCE: n down to 0.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
And then the only one left
is j, so i in, and then j
goes from where to where?
AUDIENCE: j goes to s.
AUDIENCE: It can go
either direction.
PROFESSOR: Can it?
What do the
dependencies look like?
When I'm computing i, j, I
want i plus 1 and j minus--
so I'm looking at lower j's,
higher i's and lower j's.
AUDIENCE: But it's
always higher i's.
Doesn't that mean
in this for loop
that you're already going to
have calculated the next right
column, so it
doesn't matter where
the column-- I may be wrong.
PROFESSOR: You're right.
Fine.
OK, both orders work.
I just looked at
this because I wanted
to have a nice, simple--
but fine, both work.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
You mean reversing j works?
PROFESSOR: Yes, because
we're iterating over i
before iterating over j.
Of course, this
makes more sense.
Just because they're
both good answers
doesn't mean you should
choose the one that
requires more thinking.
I always like the answer
that requires the least
amount of thinking to
prove that it's correct.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean
you're starting with a full--
PROFESSOR: I start here.
AUDIENCE: But if you're
going from s down to 0,
then you're starting
down at the corner, which
means you have a full knapsack,
so that doesn't make sense.
PROFESSOR: So the argument
was when I compute this,
I'm looking one
right, i plus 1j,
and then I'm looking
somewhere here.
And I've already
computed this column,
so it doesn't matter
if I go up or down.
And that argument is
correct because first I'm
going to compute this column,
then this column, then
this column, then this column.
By the way, what's this column?
This column is the
initial condition.
Now that we figured out
the topological sort,
let's try to compute
values here and see
what the initial
condition should be.
So if I want to
compute DP of 2, 0,
that is the maximum of either
DP 3, 0 or something else.
This is going to
evaluate to false,
so it's going to be this.
What should the answer be here?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
So we want DP of 3, 0 to
be 0 for this to work.
So what's a reasonable
initial condition?
AUDIENCE: Column
3 is of 0 height.
PROFESSOR: DP of
nj is 0 for all j,
pretty much what you
said in math mode.
So I'm going to have
an extra column.
This is like the Done
problem over there,
and here I'm going
to say that whenever
I'm looking at
the empty subset--
these are all suffixes.
All three items, two items,
one item, empty suffix.
Whenever I look at
the empty suffix,
I can fill up a backpack with
any weight by using no items,
and I'm going to make 0 money.
So what are the values here?
You guys nodded,
so you understood,
so then you should
be able to dictate
the values in the table.
AUDIENCE: So is that one also
0 because you can't go up
to anything, and then the next
one is 4 because you can go--
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Next one is-- so it's for
the fountain pen, right?
Last item.
AUDIENCE: Crystal ball.
PROFESSOR: So we're
going statute, ball, pen.
AUDIENCE: And this is weight
on the left side, right?
PROFESSOR: So we're
filling them like this
in the topological sort
order that we chose here.
We said this is
the order, so this
is what we're going to use
to calculate the table.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So it's still 0, then.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: 7.
PROFESSOR: So here,
this condition
is going to evaluate
to True finally,
so this is going to be the
maximum of either DP i plus 1j,
so DP of 3, 3, which is
0, or 7 plus DP of 3, 0.
So 7 plus 0, which is 7.
That's why it's 7.
AUDIENCE: 7, 7.
PROFESSOR: 7, 7.
How about this?
AUDIENCE: 0.
0.
4.
PROFESSOR: The maximum
of 0 and 4 plus 0, right?
AUDIENCE: 4.
AUDIENCE: No.
7.
PROFESSOR: So it's the maximum
of 7 or 4 plus 0, so this is 7.
AUDIENCE: 7.
11.
PROFESSOR: 7 or 4 plus 7.
Does this make
sense for everyone?
Last column.
Let's do it.
AUDIENCE: 0.
Feels like 0.
0 again.
Why not?
4.
How much does this thing weigh?
AUDIENCE: 4.
AUDIENCE: 7.
10.
PROFESSOR: Sorry
for my handwriting.
AUDIENCE: And it needs
to be 11 because you
said that'd be the answer.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So it's 11 because it's either
this guy or 10 plus DP of 1, 1.
The first item
weighs 4, so I need
to look one right and
four up when adding.
Does this make sense?
Please say yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
[INAUDIBLE] again?
I get how if you're
looking horizontally,
the top thing is the max.
It's saying DP of i plus 1 j.
PROFESSOR: So this is
looking horizontally,
and this means I
did not take item i.
AUDIENCE: You
didn't take item i,
but if you are going to take
item i, you add the value of i,
and then you look back
for DP of i plus 1,
which is the previous column,
and the row number is whatever
capacity you have left
if you did take it?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And so in
the case of cell 1,
3, if you took item one, then
capacity you'd have left is 3.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you said total
capacity three, right?
So if I take item one, how
many pounds does it have?
AUDIENCE: It has four.
PROFESSOR: Statue is
0, ball is 1, pen is 2.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
You're not using--
PROFESSOR: So I'm
using those items,
but I'm starting using
zero based indexing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but we're
going from here to here.
So I'm saying if you pick
the middle cell that's
1, 3, that one--
PROFESSOR: So this has item
one, so the ball, weight three.
If I take the ball, how
much weight do I have left?
AUDIENCE: The ball
weighs two pounds,
so you'd have three
pounds left, and that's
why you're in the three column.
PROFESSOR: I have a
backpack of three pounds,
and then I put a ball
of two pounds in it,
and I have three pounds left?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
You have three pounds left if
you put a ball and two pounds
in, right?
PROFESSOR: I have a
backpack of three pounds.
I put a ball of two pounds.
How many pounds do I
have left of capacity?
So backpack, three pounds total.
I put a ball in
that has two pounds.
How many pounds?
AUDIENCE: We have none left.
Oh, it can hold
three total pounds?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then you
have one pound left.
But we have a five
pound backpack.
PROFESSOR: Well, you said
we were looking at 3, 1.
You said we were looking here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
we're looking there.
PROFESSOR: So this means
three pound backpack,
because the sub-problem says
your weight is at most j.
AUDIENCE: Got it, OK.
Oh, I see.
So j minus si is saying--
PROFESSOR: It means you used up,
so you put up something there,
so you ate some capacity.
AUDIENCE: Well, you ate
only two pounds, though,
so why is it in row three?
PROFESSOR: You told
me to start here.
AUDIENCE: I know.
I'm trying to remember
how we got there.
PROFESSOR: You said,
let's start here.
That's why this arrow
points here to one.
You have two arrows,
2, 3, and 2, 1.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's j minus si.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
Minus 3.
AUDIENCE: So j is the amount
of weight you have left, right?
PROFESSOR: So j is
the amount of weight
I can have for this sub-problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
amount of capacity I
have still in my backpack.
PROFESSOR: Let's talk about
pseudo polynomial time
very quickly and what
does it mean, OK?
And you guys will promise to
look at the recitation notes
and look at the other
problems, right?
So incentive for that.
Problem two is
easier than knapsack,
so if you get that, that should
be a good confirmation that you
got knapsack.
Problem three is a bit
harder than problem two,
but it shows up on
interviews, so you
want to understand
problem three.
I got problem two
twice in four years,
so there's a decent
chance that you'll get it.
So you want to get
to problem three,
so you should go
through problem two.
AUDIENCE: How many times
have you got problem three?
PROFESSOR: Twice in
four years, so that's
the problem that
you want to get to.
Problem two is a stepping stone.
So running time for
dynamic programming.
How many sub-problems?
AUDIENCE: Same, ns.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Sub-problems.
How many sub-problems
do I look at when
I compute the answer
of a sub-problem?
Two, right?
So order one.
So this is how
much time it takes
to compute the answer
to a sub-problem,
because I have the
max of two elements,
so it's constant time.
So the total running time is?
AUDIENCE: Order ns.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Order of ns.
This polynomial, is
this the same kind
of algorithm as Dijkstra?
AUDIENCE: Pseudo polynomial.
PROFESSOR: Pseudo polynomial.
AUDIENCE: Don't know why.
PROFESSOR: So
intuitively, the problem
is s shows up in
your running here,
and s is the property
of your input numbers.
It's not how many elements
you have in the input.
It's what's inside
one of those elements.
So let's see why that matters.
Let's look at the
practical example.
AUDIENCE: What about
measuring in cubic inches
or cubic centimeters?
Is that a problem?
It would take a lot longer if
we do it in cubic centimeters.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but then you could
argue that if it's an integer
amount of cubic inches,
you should divide
everything by that.
Where this really
matters is suppose
you have a 100 item
input, so 100 items.
What's the worst case
input on a 32-bit machine?
An input looks like
this, by the way.
How many elements you have,
so 3, and then for each item,
what's the weight
and what's the value?
So then we're going to have
three weights, which I believe
are 4, 2, 3.
You guys have to
take my word for it.
And then I have three
values, which are 10, 4, 7.
Let's not worry
about the values.
I claim that they're irrelevant.
You can convince
yourselves afterwards
that that's the case.
Let's only look at this.
The weights have to be between
0 and what for the problem
to make sense?
AUDIENCE: 5.
PROFESSOR: If I have a
weight bigger than this,
I know I'm not going
to take that item.
How many bits do I need to
represent these weights?
AUDIENCE: Log s.
PROFESSOR: It's log
s plus 1 technically,
but if I write order
of log s, I'm good.
AUDIENCE: Times the
number of items.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So if I want to
represent all of them,
I have order of n times
log s, plus the number
of bits required
to represent this.
This is log n.
So log n is smaller than n.
I'm not going to add it here.
So this is my input size.
This is how many bits
I need for the input.
So the worst case input
on a 32-bit machine
is going to have
roughly 3,200 bits.
What's the worst
case s that I can
represent on a 32-bit machine?
These are all 32-bit numbers.
AUDIENCE: You mean each of the
weights are 32-bit numbers?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what's the worst
case s I can represent?
AUDIENCE: 2 to 31 minus 1.
PROFESSOR: Which is roughly
4 times 10 to the ninth.
So the worst case
running time is?
Roughly ns, right?
So n times s, which means
roughly 100 times 10
to the ninth, which means 4
times 10 to the 11 operations.
Now, suppose we're
looking at the worst case
input on a 64-bit machine.
Still 100 items.
What's the input size?
AUDIENCE: To the 21
total at the end.
PROFESSOR: That's
how many operations.
Let's go through
it step by step.
How many bits of input?
AUDIENCE: 6,400.
AUDIENCE: Where
does that come from?
AUDIENCE: 100 items
times 32 bits.
PROFESSOR: 100 items.
Each item weight has 64 bits.
What's the worst case s?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the 64.
PROFESSOR: 2 to the 64 minus 1.
Doesn't matter too much.
It's 1 times 10 to the 19th,
1.6 times 10 to the 19th.
So the worst case
running time is?
AUDIENCE: 10 to the 21.
PROFESSOR: 10 to the 21.
So what happened?
I increased my word size.
The running time
increased quadratically.
This is not a
polynomial increase.
What's the problem here?
Why is this the case?
If I write log s as
b, so log s becomes
b, what's the input size?
AUDIENCE: nb.
PROFESSOR: Yep. n times
log s equals n times b,
so this is the input size.
Now, what is the running time?
AUDIENCE: The number
of operations?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: n times 2 to the b.
n times s, and s is 2 to the b.
So this is the problem.
This is a polynomial
in n and b, but here,
if I write the input this
way, I have b as an exponent.
So if I double
the number of bits
by doubling the field
size, my running time
increases quadratically,
so this is not polynomial.
However, if I write it
as order of n times s,
this looks like a polynomial.
So it looks like a
polynomial, but it's not truly
a polynomial, so that's why
it's pseudo, as in fake.
AUDIENCE: So it's
actually exponential.
PROFESSOR: It's not exponential.
So an exponential
algorithm for this means
try all the possible
subsets, and that's
order of 2 to the n times
n to compute the sum.
This is exponential, right?
You have n here.
It's clear.
AUDIENCE: I know, but
if you have 2 to the b,
that seems pretty clear as well.
PROFESSOR: Well, you have
to look inside this s
and see what it means.
That's the difference.
So by increasing
the number of items,
if you double the
number of items
but you don't do anything
to the word size,
then your running time is
going to increase polynomially,
but if you change
the field size,
it's going to increase
exponentially.
So pseudo polynomial means
watch out, there's a trap.
It's not really polynomial.
If you increase the input size
by increasing the number width,
bad stuff is going to happen.
So think of Dijkstra.
What's the running
time of Dijkstra?
You count the number of
vertices, the number of edges,
and you have a polynomial
in that, right?
You don't have to look
at the number size.
You don't have to look at
any weird stuff like that.
Here, you do.
That's the difference.
Does it make more sense?
So whenever you have an
input number that shows up
in your running time, instead
of how many numbers you have,
that means there's a trap.
That's pseudo polynomial.
AUDIENCE: So it's just
like having some constant
that depends on something?
PROFESSOR: It's not a constant.
AUDIENCE: I mean coefficient.
AUDIENCE: Once you set it,
it's a constant, right?
PROFESSOR: I mean, that's
true for everything, right?
You can say that you have 10 to
the 80 atoms in the universe,
so all the numbers that you work
with are at most 10 to the 80.
Therefore, your running
time is order one
no matter what you do,
and then running times
are no longer useful.
You have to draw
a line somewhere.
AUDIENCE: I think it's just like
s, if it depends on your field
size and you can scale
it, it's kind of like--
PROFESSOR: So
asymptotic running time.
What's the point of that?
How do our algorithms scale?
As our data becomes
bigger and bigger,
what happens to
the running time?
This pseudo polynomial
thing tells you
that if you're shifting
to a larger number size,
to a larger word size,
then your running time
is going to explode.
It's not going to
scale linearly.
Still don't buy it?
AUDIENCE: I trust you, I just--
AUDIENCE: So it's only dependent
on the field in this case.
PROFESSOR: Do you guys
want to look over Dijkstra
and see what the input
to Dijkstra looks like
and why that's different?
Do you think that's
worth your time,
given that this
is what's standing
between you and the weekend?
AUDIENCE: What time is it?
PROFESSOR: If you guys want
to, I'm willing to do it.
AUDIENCE: It's 4:07.
I'll stay.
PROFESSOR: Well, if you
guys want to go, you can go.
I will draw this
for the people who
still want to know
what it looks like.
Dijkstra.
What's the input to Dijkstra?
It's a graph, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, nodes and edges.
PROFESSOR: What does
the graph look like?
It's some number
of nodes, so it's
a single number-- that's
the number of nodes--
that has log v bits in it.
And then for each edge, we have
three numbers-- first vertex,
second vertex, and the weight.
What are the sizes
of these numbers?
Log v, log v, and the last one?
AUDIENCE: Log w?
PROFESSOR: OK.
And what's w?
AUDIENCE: Maximum weight.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is a property of
the field size, right?
Let's look at v, actually.
So we have E edges here, right?
So the input size is going to
be log v bits plus E times log v
plus log w.
AUDIENCE: How did you get that?
PROFESSOR: Because I have the
edges, so I have E of these.
I only have one vertex count,
but then I have E edges,
and each edge has three
numbers, and these
are the widths of the numbers.
AUDIENCE: Is the
adjacent edges to v?
Is that right?
You say you have E edges.
PROFESSOR: I'm
assuming it's a list,
so the most compact
representation
of edges, I think-- or
it might be a reasonably
compact representation is that
you have the list of edges.
So you have a graph
that has five nodes,
and then you have an edge
that goes from 1 to 2,
and then weight 3, an edge that
goes from 1 to 5, weight 4.
AUDIENCE: If you use
a number, it's not a--
PROFESSOR: Well, do I need
anything else for vertices?
Not really, right?
AUDIENCE: So v1 and v2 are
neighbors of capital V?
PROFESSOR: So v1, v2, w,
these are the first edge.
Each edge has these fields.
AUDIENCE: This is the
entire graph in one thing.
PROFESSOR: This is the entire
graph as a list of numbers,
and this is how
many bits it takes
to represent the
graph in a reasonably
compact representation.
Now let's say little v is
log v, little w is log w.
So then this is order of how
many bits do I have here?
E times v plus w plus v.
I just replaced the logs
with these variables.
This is how many bits.
Now, how many operations
does Dijkstra take?
What's the running time?
AUDIENCE: Well, it depends on--
AUDIENCE: E log v.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
it be E plus v?
That's the fastest one, right?
But I think practically,
it's only going to be--
PROFESSOR: So this
is E plus v log
v, the fastest
theoretical limit.
This is still smaller
than E log v. This
is going to make my life easier.
So this is smaller than this.
If this thing is polynomial,
this is polynomial for sure.
E log v is E times little v.
So how many bits in the input?
E times v plus w.
How many operations?
E times v. Any
exponential anywhere here?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you
change the size of v?
That looks fine.
PROFESSOR: Well, so there is
a trick that v is 2 to the v,
right?
So you can say
that this is order
of-- so this is
definitely bigger than 2
to the little v
times v, but then you
have the same
thing in the input.
So the input also has at least
2 to the little v times v bits.
But don't worry about that.
That's too much.
The point is if you're worrying
about this, don't worry.
The math still works out.
So whatever you have
here as an input,
the running time is
going to be a polynomial
in the size of the input.
What happens if you
double the word size?
have bigger weights?
AUDIENCE: Everything like
v is multiplied by 2,
and w is multiplied by 2 and
everything in this problem,
right?
PROFESSOR: So if you're
doubling the word size,
then this is going to double,
this is going to double.
Everything's fine.
What if you double the
size of the weights?
AUDIENCE: That only
adds an extra bit.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
So if you double the size
of the weight numbers?
So if you move from 32-bit
weights to 64-bit weights?
AUDIENCE: That's still a
constant factor, right?
PROFESSOR: What happens
to the running time?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
PROFESSOR: Nothing.
w does not show up in Dijkstra.
If it would, then
we'd be trouble.
It wouldn't be
polynomial anymore.
AUDIENCE: But
practically, you will
be accessing that number, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but that shows up
in the cost of one operation.
That's why I'm saying this
is how many operations
you do, how many
arithmetic operations.
Then the model of computation
that we use is RAM,
and that says that
you can do any math
operation in order one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So here, my
number in the input,
s, which is the
size of a weight,
showed up in the running time.
AUDIENCE: Oh, the
size of the input
showed up in the running time.
PROFESSOR: So the size
of the input is OK,
but one number in
the input showed up,
whereas here,
that's not the case.
The weights do not show
up in the running time.
AUDIENCE: So why don't we just
always run Dijkstra, then?
PROFESSOR: Actually for this
problem, for the knapsack
problem, you can't find an
algorithm that is polynomial.
If you do, there's a
$1 million prize for it
because you just proved
that p equals mp.
This is the best we
can do for knapsack.
AUDIENCE: Is counting
sort pseudo linear,
because you need to
have a maximum, a range?
Does that make sense?
PROFESSOR: Counting sort.
AUDIENCE: Depends on your range.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but the
range shows up under a log.
You're allowed to have logs.
You're allowed to have log w.
You're not allowed to have w.
It's dependent on the
size of the input.
If you double the
number size, then you're
going to have twice
as many rounds,
but you don't have an
exponential number of rounds.
Sorry.
You're thinking
of counting sort.
I thought radix sort.
Radix sort doesn't
matter because you
assume we can do
everything in-- never mind.
You're right for counting sort.
Sorry.
I was confusing counting
sort with radix sort.
So for counting sort,
yeah, it's not linear.
It's linear in your
range size, which
is not linear in the
input size, which
is why we don't
do counting sort.
We do radix sort.
AUDIENCE: We do counting
sort in radix sort?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But radix sort limits the
size of the range, right?
That's the point of radix sort.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I see what you're thinking.
So doing counting
sort with each number?
AUDIENCE: Right, with
really big numbers,
taking a really long time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that
would take a long time.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
That is very true.
If you try to do pure counting
sort on 64-bit numbers,
you're going to run out of RAM.
Does this make some sense?
OK.
Promise to look over the
other problems, and in return,
given that I didn't have
time to cover them here,
I promise to answer
any emails you
guys might ask me
over the weekend.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Awesome.